hello i'm caslin fields and i'm a
developer advocate at google cloud
today i'll be walking through the basics
to get started with anthocon bare metal
let's get going
anthos is a platform made up of a
variety of products
all designed with enterprise use cases
in mind one key factor of enterprise
ecosystems is that they often span
hybrid and multi-cloud environments the
enthos platform is designed to give a
consistent user experience across
platforms
you can expect that products with anthos
in the name will have features and
capabilities designed for hybrid and
multi-cloud environments
today i'll be talking about anthoconbear
metal
which is a tool you can use to
incorporate your on-prem environments
into the anthos platform
anthocon bare metal gives you the google
provided consistent experience
and useful tools and features of anthos
for you to run on your own
self-managed hardware we know that every
environment is different
so there are a variety of supported
configurations which you can learn more
about in the documentation
the install process with anthocon bare
metal includes an
integrated preflight check to ensure
your system meets requirements
the installer itself allows you to
declaratively deploy anthos
components onto your own on-prem systems
anthocon bare metal can be deployed on
either physical or
virtual infrastructure and supports a
variety of linux distributions
such as red hat enterprise linux centos
or ubuntu anthocon bare metal comes with
an
out of the box kubernetes networking
stack including load balancing and
overlay networking
there are some basic requirements around
networking for the hardware you're using
to run your anthocon bare metal cluster
which you can learn more about in the
documentation
integration with the container storage
interface allows for integration with
your on-prem storage infrastructure
anthocon bare metal provides tooling to
perform smooth
in-place upgrades and includes
out-of-the-box integration with cloud
operations
formerly known as stackdriver for system
as well as application logs and metrics
as well as the potential to integrate
with other observability tools
while anthos is largely centered around
kubernetes we know not
every workload may be able to run in
containers so enthos can also make use
of
cubevert cubevert is an open source
project allowing kubernetes to manage
virtual machines
like it manages containers there are a
number of prerequisites your environment
will need to meet
in order to be used with anthocon bare
metal
here you can see a description of the
hardware environment i'll be using in
this demo
i'll be using three intel next unit of
computing nodes
or intel nux i've imaged each of these
to be running ubuntu 20.04.1
server there are a few linux
distributions which meet the current
requirements for anthocon bare metal
be sure to check the documentation for
the latest operating system and hardware
requirements
i've upgraded two of my nux to have 32
gigabytes of ram
each these will be the nodes where the
kubernetes cluster and therefore any
workloads will
be run the other nook is to be used as
an
admin workstation this can be any linux
workstation
i'll use this node to ssh into the
others to do any configuration
and to run the bmctl command which is
the command line tool for anthocon bare
metal
there are also a number of prerequisites
to set up on the google cloud side
you will need a project and sufficient
privileges on that project
to configure anthocon bare metal you
will also need to configure a few
service accounts for things like logging
and monitoring
and to connect your bare metal cluster
to anthos in gcp
now let's take a look at the process to
set up an anthocon bare metal cluster on
this configuration in order to create a
cluster for anthocon bare metal
we'll need a yaml file to describe our
kubernetes cluster
we can create a convenient base file
using the command
bmctl create config
dash c and giving it a cluster name
there are several components that will
need updating in the created file
i've already created one and configured
it for my environment
let's take a closer look
if you're familiar with kubernetes yaml
manifests
this probably looks familiar to you
at the top of this file we have a
variety of key file paths
which we will need for cluster
installation then we begin blocks
declaring api objects
the first interesting one here is the
cluster definition
you can see here that we can define a
cluster type
anthocon bare metal offers various
architecture configurations
that can be useful in multi-cluster
environments or
single cluster environments such as at
the edge
we will use gke connect to register this
cluster with
anthos
here we define the information for our
cluster's control plane
in my case as this is just a demo
environment
i will be using a single machine for my
control plane for
high availability you would generally
want three
here i have the ip my admin workstation
will use to connect to the control plane
node
next i need to specify the ip ranges
kubernetes will use to create pods and
services there is also a load balancer
component needed for anthocon bare metal
this can run on the control plane nodes
or as a separate machine
or set of machines in my demo
environment i will be using my control
plane node also
as my load balancer so here i specify a
virtual ip on my network
to be used for the load balancer i also
specify a range of ips for use by the
load balancer to expose my services
if you're using a proxy you will need to
add some configuration here
i'm not so i'll leave this all commented
out here we see some information used
for logging in metrics
and here at the bottom of the file is
the definition of our worker node pool
the machines in this pool are where
workloads will actually be run
as i mentioned in my case i have only
one
now i'm going to use bmctl the antho
spare metal command line tool
to deploy the cluster i've defined to do
that i'll run
bmctl create
cluster dash c and give it a cluster
name
this will take a few minutes to complete
now we've successfully deployed our
cluster
we can confirm that we can connect to
our cluster using cubectl
we can see in the output of our cluster
creation the cubeconfig file we'll need
to use to connect the cluster
running this command
[Music]
shows me the nodes of my two node demo
cluster i'll also go ahead and export my
cube config
so i don't have to specify it in each
command
the bare metal command line tool not
only created the cluster
but also connected the cluster to anthos
in google cloud
so we should be able to see our cluster
in the anthos dashboard
in the google cloud console as well
here in the google cloud console we will
go to the anthos dashboard
and here in the anthos dashboard you can
see that in the cluster status box
it lists one healthy cluster if we click
view clusters we can see our cluster
here
this is the cluster we just created on a
set of intel noc hardware
and now we can see and manage it in
google cloud
now let's deploy an app to our cluster
for this demo
i'm going to use a very simple hello
world app
if we look at our deployment yaml file
you can see that i'm defining a
kubernetes deployment here
with three replicas and using a hello
app
container image
[Music]
now to create my deployment i'll run
cubectl
create dash f and give it my deployment
file
[Music]
you can see that the deployment has been
created now we can check it with cube
ctl
get deploy you can see our deployment is
up
with three ready pods now i'll create a
service
using the myservice.yaml file
you can see that this is a service of
type load balancer which we'll be able
to reach
on port 80. we'll create this with
cubectl
create dashf
and give it the file name and we can
take a look at our service with cube ctl
get svc or service using my services
external ip
provided by the load balancer i can run
a curl command on that ip to see that my
app is running properly
here you can see in our output that my
application is running as i expect
in this demo we walked through the
requirements to create an anthocon bare
metal cluster
saw some of the benefits you get from
anthocyan google cloud
and deployed an application to our
on-prem cluster
check out google cloud for more on
running enterprise grade
hybrid and multi-cloud architectures
with anthos
you